did you grow up helping mom or maybe mom
and dad at home in the kitchen well
maybe it was just setting the table or
getting to clean up the dishes after
dinner well there's a company that
believes letting the kids wear the apron
can cook up some terrific skills and
stir their imagination this is a
wonderful example of a recipe that
starts out with
a type of food that your kid might
already be comfortable with my children
love bagels and cream cheese but some of
the veggies and fruits are a bit of a
stretch
mimi sabo is a mom and food writer for a
unique kid's cooking company called
kidster well the belief baked into each
recipe is that kitchen time with the
kids is quality time which can help them
cook up some useful life skills
for this recipe it's actually
uses a lot of basic skills like chopping
so i have some of my vegetables
ready-made here
we basic skills like chopping roasting
um but then also the fun of presentation
you know as a parent you know your job
is to support your child and help them
but it's also to realize when you need
to step back and let them take on some
new skills and realize what they're
capable of
kitchen's a great place to do that
well mimi says the recipes open up young
minds to exploring new and nutritious
foods and steps like measuring and
portioning also helps improve math
skills and they learn to be resourceful
you know my kid has has gained more
confidence they've become more of a
problem solver you know i mean the
kitchen is a place where okay i don't
have buttermilk for this recipe what am
i going to do i got to figure it out
those are skills you can take with you
in life
well the free website is full of fun
foodie tips and easy kid-friendly
recipes but the real secret ingredients
come in the monthly subscription kits
addressed to your child chef with new
recipes shopping lists step-by-step
instructions and photos of what the
food's supposed to look like as they
cook and a fun new kitchen tool designed
just for small hands really try to think
we try to think about the skills we want
the children to learn and based on the
kinds of kits we've sent out before
we want to think about ways that we can
expand their knowledge about the world
well you can check out the website again
it's absolutely free and then if you
want to subscribe to the kids there are
different levels of subscriptions at
different prices go to kidster.com
learn all about it so